This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. All over Oakland right now, people are wearing warrior shirts and find their warriors flags from their cars. And as much as we like our hometown team here at Nine and Empire, we've been following these NBA finals for another design-related reason. When you watch the games in Toronto, the whole stadium is filled with people wearing red raptors, jerseys, and these t-shirts that say we the north on them.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。现在奥克兰到处都是穿着勇士队队服、车上插着勇士队旗帜的人。尽管我们和九号帝国（Nine and Empire）的各位一样喜欢家乡球队，但我们关注今年的 NBA 总决赛，其实还有另一个与设计有关的原因。当你观看在多伦多举行的比赛时，整个体育馆里挤满了身穿红色猛龙队球衣、印有“我们北方”（We the North）字样T恤的人。
But every now and then, you see little flashes of purple. Those bold fans are wearing one of the most polarizing jerseys in sports history. A jersey, we actually did a whole episode about last year. So in honor of the Toronto Raptors and the beautifully ugly jersey they gave the world, we're gonna rerun that episode for you today, plus an update from our newest 99Pi team member,
但偶尔，你也能看到一闪而过的紫色。那些大胆的球迷穿着体育史上最具争议的球衣之一。一件我们去年专门做过一期节目的球衣。因此，为了致敬多伦多猛龙队以及他们带给世界的这件美得别具一格的球衣，我们今天将为您重播那期节目，此外还有我们最新的 99Pi 团队成员带来的最新报道，
Chris Baroube, who was raised and currently resides in the Great North. He is very excited right now. Stay with us. Go all of us. Buzzer. On a March afternoon in 1996, the Toronto Raptors, a brand new team in the NBA at the time,
克里斯·巴鲁比（Chris Baroube），他在大北方长大并目前居住在那里。他现在非常兴奋。请继续收听我们节目。我们所有人一起。蜂鸣器。在 1996 年 3 月的一个下午，当时还是 NBA 全新球队的多伦多猛龙队，
were playing the Chicago Bulls. The Bulls were the best team in the league, and the Raptors were pretty terrible. 36,000 fans showed up that day, and the Raptors actually beat the Bulls. But it was a mostly meaningless game at the end of the season. This is Reporter Whitney Jones. And what's so interesting to me about this game isn't who won or how the teams played, but the way they looked, there's the bulls who are just classic NBA. They've had the same logos since 1966.
正在对阵芝加哥公牛队。公牛队是联盟中最好的球队，而猛龙队则相当糟糕。那天有 36,000 名球迷到场，猛龙队竟然击败了公牛队。但这只是一场在赛季末期基本上没有什么意义的比赛。这是记者惠特尼·琼斯（Whitney Jones）。对我来说，这场比赛最有趣的地方不在于谁赢了，或者球队表现如何，而是他们的外观。公牛队的风格非常经典 NBA。自 1966 年以来，他们的标志就一直没变过。
They're wearing their red-awaited jerseys that look basically like every Chicago Bulls jersey ever. It's red with the word bulls written across the front and black and white lettering. It's simple, the word bulls written across the front and black and white lettering. It's simple, classic. But then, there's the Toronto Raptors. The team is wearing their white home uniforms, which have jagged, silver and black pinstripes, as if they were cut by slashing Raptor claws, and then across the whole front. There's a giant red basketball-playing dinosaur, who himself is wearing sneakers and a uniform a totally different uniform and is dribbling a basketball.
他们穿着红白相间的球衣，基本上看起来就像每一件芝加哥公牛队的球衣一样。那是红色的，正面写着“公牛”（Bulls）字样，配有黑白字母。很简单，正面写着“公牛”字样，配有黑白字母。很简单，经典。但是，再看看多伦多猛龙队。球队穿着他们的白色主场队服，上面有锯齿状的银色和黑色细条纹，就好像被猛龙锋利的爪子划破了一样，然后在整个正面上。有一个巨大的红色打篮球的恐龙，它自己穿着运动鞋和队服——一套完全不同的队服——还在运着篮球。
And that was just their home uniform. The road jerseys that year were even more fun. They were bright purple. All of this, including the Raptor's name, had been inspired by the Velociraptors in the wildly successful movie Jurassic Park. But these jerseys got compared to a different, much friendlier 90s dinosaur. That's now known as the Barney design because they're road uniform as purple. a barney design because their road uniform was purple. This is Paul Lucas, uniform obsessive and writer of a column at ESPN called UniWatch. It just, it looks so cartoonish and so ridiculous. You look at it and it's like really? That's a professional, like top level team.
而这还只是他们的主场队服。那一年的客场球衣更有趣。它们是亮紫色的。所有这一切，包括猛龙队的名字，灵感都来自轰动全球的电影《侏罗纪公园》中的迅猛龙。但这些球衣却被拿来与 90 年代另一只更友善、更温和的恐龙作比较。现在这被称为巴尼（Barney）设计，因为他们的客场队服是紫色的。因为他们的客场队服是紫色的，所以这被称为巴尼设计。这是保罗·卢卡斯（Paul Lucas），球衣狂热爱好者兼 ESPN 专栏“UniWatch”的撰稿人。它看起来太卡通了，太荒谬了。你看它就会觉得，真的吗？这是一支职业的、顶级水平的球队。
The Raptors jersey may have been particularly garish, but it wasn't the only jersey of its kind. The 90s were this insane decade of NBA uniform design, and produced some of the wildest jerseys that have ever graced a basketball court. Loud, wacky designs, the likes of which had never been seen before, and haven't been seen since. Like the Atlanta Hawks read in black jersey with a fierce looking hawk swooping in across the entire front of it, holding a basketball in its little talons.
猛龙队的球衣可能特别艳俗，但它并不是同类球衣中的唯一一件。90 年代是 NBA 球衣设计疯狂的十年，诞生了篮球场上见过的最狂野的一些球衣。张扬、古怪的设计，是以前从未见过，以后也再未见过的。比如亚特兰大老鹰队的红黑球衣，正面中央有一只凶猛的老鹰俯冲而下，它的爪子里抓着一个篮球。
One of the Milwaukee Bucks green uniform with a giant picture of a purple stag. Paul Lucas called this one great. I mean great in the sense that it was so awful it was great. They had this purple garish purple and green color pattern, it just looks ridiculous, but it definitely, all these designs definitely, they pushed and extended the idea of what a basketball uniform could be or should be. And many of these designs can be traced back to one man. I'm Tom O'Grady. I join the NBA in 1990 as League's first creative director. Tom grew up in Chicago, sketching and resketching the logos of his hometown Chicago Black Hawks, another classic pro hockey teams.
密尔沃基雄鹿队的一款绿色球衣，上面有一只巨大的紫色雄鹿图案。保罗·卢卡斯称赞这款球衣“绝了”。我的意思是，从“丑到极致就是绝”这个角度来说，它确实绝。它们采用了这种紫色、艳俗的紫色和绿色配色方案，看起来确实很荒谬，但毫无疑问，所有这些设计确实都推动并拓展了人们对篮球球衣可以是什么样、应该是什么样的想象。其中许多设计都可以追溯到一个人。我是汤姆·奥格雷迪（Tom O'Grady）。我于 1990 年加入 NBA，担任联盟首位创意总监。汤姆在芝加哥长大，从小就喜欢素描和重新绘制他家乡球队芝加哥黑鹰队（另一支经典的职业冰球队）的标志。
Tom's love for sports and eye-catching art made this new NBA gig a dream job. My first day at the NBA was just filled with excitement. I'd always been a big sports fan and I loved design and my study graphic design here at Columbia College back in Chicago. So when I walked in the door in June of 1990, I kind of had to pinch myself because I really didn't believe what was happening. Before Tom O'Grady joined the league, most NBA jerseys looks something like that classic bulls jersey. They had simple two or three color schemes with the team names across the front.
汤姆对体育的热爱和对引人注目的艺术的敏锐眼光，使这份新的 NBA 工作成为了一份梦想中的工作。我在 NBA 的第一天充满了兴奋。我一直是个超级体育迷，我热爱设计，并在芝加哥的哥伦比亚学院学习平面设计。所以当我在 1990 年 6 月走进大门时，我简直得掐自己一下，因为我真不敢相信这一切正在发生。在汤姆·奥格雷迪加入联盟之前，大多数 NBA 球衣看起来都有点像那件经典的公牛队球衣。它们采用简单的两到三种配色方案，正面印有球队名称。
There might have been a stripe here or there, maybe a cool font, but that was about it. And they weren't designed by designers. The process of designing team uniforms was mostly left up to team equipment managers, because they were responsible for getting the players outfitted to play the games. Mostly this consisted of the equipment managers flipping through a catalog, choosing a design they liked with the right colors. It was not a sophisticated business, let's say that. They were happy just to get uniforms on the player's backs. But that was all about to change, because in 1988, Charlotte Hornets introduced a radical new idea, the color teal. In this archival news footage from 1988, Hornets player Kelly Trapuka stands on stage in front of flashing
可能会有一两条条纹，或者一个很酷的字体，但基本上也就这些了。而且它们不是由设计师设计的。球队队服的设计过程大多交给了球队的装备经理，因为他们负责为球员准备比赛服装。这通常包括装备经理翻阅目录，选择一个自己喜欢的、颜色合适的图案。可以说，这不是一项很成熟的业务。他们只是很高兴能把队服穿在球员身上。但这一切都将改变，因为在 1988 年，夏洛特黄蜂队引入了一个激进的新想法——蒂芙尼蓝（teal，湖蓝色）。在 1988 年的这段新闻资料画面中，黄蜂队球员凯利·特拉普卡（Kelly Tripucka）站在闪烁的闪光灯前。
cameras. Then he rips off his teal-terraway warm-ups to reveal the Hornets' new uniforms. T.O. was not a traditional NBA jersey color. It's not NBA red, it's not NBA blue, it's not Celtic screen, it's not Lakers yellow. Tom O'Grady had nothing to do with the T.O. Hornets uniform, but he took it as a sign but it's not NBA blue, it's not Celtic screen, it's not Lakers yellow. Tom O'Grady had nothing to do with the Teal Hornets uniform, but he took it as a sign that the league was ready for bolder designs.
然后他扯掉蒂芙尼蓝色的撕裂式热身服，露出了黄蜂队的新队服。蒂芙尼蓝并不是传统的 NBA 球衣颜色。它不是 NBA 红，不是 NBA 蓝，不是凯尔特人绿，也不是湖人黄。汤姆·奥格雷迪与黄蜂队的蒂芙尼蓝球衣没有任何关系，但他将其视为一个信号——但这并非 NBA 蓝，并非凯尔特人绿，也并非湖人黄。汤姆·奥格雷迪与蒂芙尼蓝黄蜂球衣毫无关系，但他将其视为一个信号，表明联盟已经准备好迎接更大胆的设计。
It was kind of a leap of faith for the league to say, you know, this is not really something we've seen before, but as an expansion team, we'll probably let you have this one because maybe there's something new we can learn from this. And it turned out fans loved the teal hornets Jersey. It looked fresh and different. It was really very popular. They soon became known as the Men of Teal.
对于联盟来说，这算是一种信仰之跃，他们会说，“你知道的，这确实是我们以前没怎么见过的东西，但作为一支扩张球队，我们可能会让你保留这个，因为也许我们可以从中学到一些新东西。”事实证明，球迷们非常喜欢蒂芙尼蓝的黄蜂球衣。它看起来清新而与众不同。它确实非常受欢迎。他们很快就被称为“蒂芙尼蓝战队”。
And all of a sudden, the Charlotte Hornets had gained great recognition before they'd ever played a basketball game. When Tom O'Grady was hired as the NBA's first creative director two years later in 1990, he wanted to push Jersey design even further, not just the colors, but the designs on the uniforms. Until the early 90s, there had been real limits to how wild you could get with these designs. Because all the details, the numbers, the names and the logos, had to be sewn on.
突然之间，夏洛特黄蜂队在甚至还没打过一场 NBA 比赛之前，就已经获得了极高的知名度。两年后的 1990 年，当汤姆·奥格雷迪被聘为 NBA 首位创意总监时，他希望将球衣设计推向更远的境界，不仅是颜色，还有队服上的图案。直到 90 年代初，这些设计的疯狂程度一直受到实质性的限制。因为所有的细节——数字、名字和标志——都必须缝上去。
To do any kind of complicated graphics, it would have taken a massive amount of embroidery. And all that thread would have added additional weight and made the Jersey hotter to wear. But soon after Tom O'Grady joined the NBA, he would get some new tools to work with. Computer programs like Photoshop and Illustrator helped him dream up new logo designs. And there was a new technique to get those drawings
要制作任何复杂的图案，都需要大量的刺绣。而所有的这些线都会增加额外的重量，并使球衣穿着时更加闷热。但就在汤姆·奥格雷迪加入 NBA 不久后，他将获得一些用于工作的新工具。诸如 Photoshop 和 Illustrator 之类的电脑程序帮助他构思出新的标志设计。而且还有了一种新技法，可以将这些画作
onto a Jersey. It was called die sublimation. Sublimation changed everything die sublimation. Sublimation changed everything. Sublimation is a process of printing die directly into the fabric. Now for the first time you could design something in Photoshop. You could make it big and you could add a bunch of different colors. Then with sublimation you could basically print that design straight onto the material without any embroidery or extra weight. So it allowed us to start to take things
印到球衣上。这被称为热升华印花（dye sublimation）。升华改变了一切——热升华。升华改变了一切。升华是将染料直接印入面料的工艺。现在，你第一次可以在 Photoshop 中进行设计。你可以把它做大，还可以添加许多不同的颜色。然后通过热升华，你基本上可以直接将该设计打印到材料上，而无需任何刺绣或额外的重量。因此，这使我们能够开始尝试一些
we would never normally even consider doing on a jersey. And we started doing more outrageous uniforms and stuff because we could. We can, so we will. Tom's first big design was for the Phoenix Suns, who were celebrating their 25th year in the league. They were moving into a new arena, and they wanted a new look.
我们以前甚至从未考虑在球衣上做的事情。我们开始制作更多离谱的队服之类的东西，因为我们能做到。我们能做到，所以我们就会去做。汤姆的第一个重大设计是为菲尼克斯太阳队制作的，当时他们正在庆祝加入联盟 25 周年。他们正要搬进一个新的球馆，并想要一个新的外观。
So Tom met with their team owner, Jerry Calangelo. Jerry was great. He was a fellow Chicagoan so as soon as you heard my accent, he's like, I think we're going to get along. I think us Chicago guys kind of get this. Here's what I want to do. I want to have a logo that's going to last for the next 25 years. I don't want to have to change it.
于是汤姆会见了他们的球队老板杰里·科朗杰洛（Jerry Colangelo）。杰里人很好。他也是芝加哥人，所以一听到我的口音，他就说：“我觉得我们能合得来。我觉得我们芝加哥人挺懂这个的。这是我想做的。我想要一个能用未来 25 年的标志。我不想经常更换它。”
So I want something futuristic but classic. So Tom and his team started on the Sun's redesign. They come up with this big basketball that's also a sun. something futuristic, but classic. So Tom and his team started on the Sun's redesign. They come up with this big basketball that's also a sun. It has these long red to orange gradient sun rays coming off of it. And then they print this and a bright purple background under their new jersey. It's not exactly what I would call classic, but it is bold.
“所以我想要一种既具未来感又经典的东西。”于是汤姆和他的团队开始了太阳队的新设计。他们设计了一个既是篮球又是太阳的大标志。一种既具未来感又经典的东西。于是汤姆和他的团队开始了太阳队的重新设计。他们想出了这个既是篮球又是太阳的大标志。它上面有从红色到橙色渐变的漫长太阳光芒。然后他们将这个图案印在明亮的紫色背景上，作为他们的新球衣。这不完全是我所谓的经典，但它确实很大胆。
Definitely bold. As luck would have it, the Phoenix Suns made it to the NBA finalsals that year, and the whole country got to see that bright purple jersey, with its blazing basketball sun, all over national TV. We got exposure for that uniform that was priceless. That changed everything for us. We were able to do things with uniforms that we could not imagine even two years before
绝对很大胆。果不其然，菲尼克斯太阳队在那一年打入了 NBA 总决赛，全国观众都在全国电视上看到了那件亮紫色的球衣，以及上面燃烧的篮球太阳。我们从那件队服中获得了无价的曝光度。这改变了我们的一切。我们能够用队服做一些甚至在两年前都无法想象的事情
that. Like a teal to Troy Piston's jersey with a flaming horse head logo or a pinstriped Houston rocket jersey featuring a cartoon rocket with an angry face on it. Over the course of the decade, two thirds of NBA teams got new uniforms with new logos and new color schemes. There was a lot of teal and purple. 3D lettering and oversized graphics were everywhere. We look back on it and say, wow,
。比如底特律活塞队带有火焰马头标志的蒂芙尼蓝球衣，或者印有带愤怒表情的卡通火箭的细条纹休斯顿火箭队球衣。在这十年里，三分之二的 NBA 球衣都换成了新标志和新配色方案。当时有大量的蒂芙尼蓝和紫色。3D 字体和超大图形随处可见。我们回过头来看会说：“哇，
this stuff is pretty outlandish, but it's okay because that's what was happening at a time. The technology led us to the wild. And Tom's boss, NBA Commissioner David Stern, gave him the freedom to keep pushing the designs further. He said, you know, if this is what's selling and if you're telling me this is what's going to work at retail, um, count me in. Before the 90s, the NBA wasn't doing much with merchandising. If a fan wanted to buy a jersey, they had to pay the full cost of a genuine,
这些东西太离谱了，但没关系，因为那是当时的时代背景。这项技术将我们引向了狂野。”而汤姆的老板、NBA 总裁大卫·斯特恩（David Stern）给了他继续推动设计发展的自由。他说：“你知道，如果这东西好卖，如果你告诉我这在零售端会火，嗯，算我一个。”在 90 年代之前，NBA 在商品销售方面并没有做太多事情。如果球迷想买一件球衣，他们必须支付一件正品、
stitched NBA game jersey, which was sometimes over $200. But with all these popular new designs, Tom and others at the NBA got thinking. Why don't we have a jersey that we can sell for about $45 to $50 that looks similar to the game jersey. And we saw this business explode you know in five years. It went from almost like a baseline of nothing to a multi-million dollar business, largely on the jerseys that we were designing. The era about landage NBA uniforms reached its apex in 1995. With that jersey we talked about at the beginning, that one from Toronto, the one that some people call the Barney design.
缝制好的 NBA 比赛球衣的全价，有时甚至超过 200 美元。但随着所有这些广受欢迎的新设计涌现，汤姆和 NBA 的其他人开始思考：为什么我们不能推出一款售价大约 45 到 50 美元、看起来与比赛球衣类似的球衣呢？你知道的，我们在五年内看到了这项业务的爆发式增长。它几乎从零基数发展成为一个价值数百万美元的业务，很大程度上归功于我们设计的球衣。这种荒诞的 NBA 球衣时代在 1995 年达到了顶峰。就是我们在开头谈到的那件球衣，来自多伦多的那件，被一些人称为巴尼设计的球衣。
We were told directly by the team owner at the time, John Bitov, it would like the happy meal box of uniform designs. And we kind of looked at him and puzzled like, what did he mean by that? He said, I'm not going to wear this uniform forever. I don't, you know, kids don't eat out of a happy meal box forever. But if you can get the kids into your store, you're going to win them over. If happy meal design isn't a term yet,
当时的球队老板约翰·比托夫（John Bitov）直接告诉我们，它看起来就像汉堡王（Happy Meal，快乐儿童餐）的包装盒。我们当时看着他，满脸疑惑，问他这是什么意思？他说：“我不会永远穿着这件队服。你知道的，孩子们不会永远从快乐儿童餐盒里吃东西。但如果你能把孩子们吸引到你的商店里，你就能赢得他们。”如果“快乐儿童餐设计”这个词还不存在的话，
I'm making it one right now. The goal was to convince hockey loving kids in Toronto that they should care about this new basketball team. And so we created this purple uniform with these jagged edge cloth, pinstripes that looked like a raptor common ripped it. And then they slapped a big dinosaur right in the middle of it. And they made it red because Canada. He wanted red-rarapped to represent Canada, which made all the sense in the world.
我现在就要创造它。当时的目标是说服多伦多热爱冰球的孩子们，让他们也去关注这支崭新的篮球队。于是我们设计了这款紫色队服，上面有锯齿状的布料细条纹，看起来就像被猛龙撕裂过一样。然后在正中央印上了一只巨大的恐龙。而且把它做成红色是因为加拿大。他希望用红色的猛龙来代表加拿大，这在当时可以说是合情合理。
I don't know how much sense that made, but that jersey, it's all. I think it was the top-selling expansion team logo we ever did even today. The sales were through the roof. Before they ever played a game, before the team had even signed a single player, the Raptors were 7th in the league in merchandise sales.
我不知道这有多合理，但那件球衣，它太……我想这甚至是我们有史以来销量最高的扩张球队标志，直到今天也是如此。销量简直好得爆表。在他们甚至还没打过一场比赛、球队甚至还没签下任何一名球员之前，猛龙队的商品销量就在联盟中排名第七。
By the early 2000s, the NBA had become a booming global industry, and wealthy business people were suddenly interested in team ownership. People like Howard Schultz, who turned Starbucks into a multi-billion dollar business. In 2001, Schultz bought the Seattle Supersonics, and he came into the league with a whole laundry list of changes to make. He wanted to replace the hip-hop you'd hear in the arena on Game Night, with Jazz. He wanted his team to stick to the fundamentals, less flashy dunks and show-boding. He favored team basketball over individual stars,
到 2000 年代初，NBA 已经成为一个蓬勃发展的全球产业，富商们突然对拥有球队产生了兴趣。比如霍华德·舒尔茨（Howard Schultz），他把星巴克变成了一家价值数十亿美元的企业。2001 年，舒尔茨买下了西雅图超音速队，他一进入联盟就带着一长串的改革清单。他想用爵士乐取代比赛之夜在球馆里听到的嘻哈音乐。他希望他的球队回归基础，减少花哨的扣篮和炫耀。他更倾向于团队篮球，而不是个人球星，
which was actually really bad for his team because it pissed off their actual stars. Also, Schultt hated the Sonic's 90s look that had been designed by none other than our pal Tom. We were able to take this kind of basketball spinning around space needle and kind of have this super man font and added toward silics in there.
这其实对他的球队非常不利，因为这惹恼了他们真正的球星。此外，舒尔茨讨厌超音速队那套由我们的老朋友汤姆设计的 90 年代外观。我们得以把这种在太空针塔周围旋转的篮球，以及某种超人字体和斜体字结合起来。
And they changed the colors from green and gold to dark green, red and a metallic bronze. Old Howard Jazz instead of hip-hop shults was not a fan, so he hired Seattle design firm Hornel Anderson to completely remake the Sonic's graphic identity. That's Jersey's warm-ups, logos, everything. I get my pants, I was so damn excited. This is Andrew Wickland, who is the lead designer on the project. I hated what the Sonic's looked like at that time too,
并且他们把颜色从绿色和金色改成了深绿色、红色和金属青铜色。老派的爵士乐取代了嘻哈乐，舒尔茨对此并不感冒，于是他聘请了西雅图设计公司 Hornall Anderson 来彻底重塑超音速队的视觉形象。也就是球衣、热身服、标志，一切。我当时激动得裤子都要湿了。这是该项目的首席设计师安德鲁·威克兰（Andrew Wickland）。我也讨厌超音速队当时的外观，
and a lot of other teams, frankly, that had been rebranded in the 90s, so yeah, it was like kindergarten store. The direction they were given was clear. Immediately go back to the old classic green and gold color scheme and do something iconic. Howard's words were, I want this to be something that nobody would ever want to change.
坦率地说，还有许多在 90 年代进行过品牌重塑的其他球队也是如此，所以，是的，这就像幼儿园的水平。他们得到的方向很明确：立即回到老派经典的绿色和金色配色方案，并做一些具有标志性的东西。霍华德的原话是：“我希望这个东西是任何人都永远不想去改变的。”
I want it to be the Chicago Cubs, the New York Yankees, the Green Bay Packers. Those are solid shapes, simple shapes. They are simple color palettes. It's simplification. Is its strength? By the start of the 2001-2002 season, everything was in place. Green and gold, no 3-D anything, no giant logo's across the chest.
“我希望它成为芝加哥小熊队、纽约扬基队、绿湾包装工队那样的存在。那些是坚固的形状，简单的形状。它们是简单的调色板。简单化就是它的力量所在。”到 2001-2002 赛季开始时，一切都已就绪。绿色和金色，没有 3D 效果，胸前也没有巨大的标志。
The uniforms looked like an update or the ones they'd started wearing in the late 70s. But if Howard Schultz was committed to making the Sonics an iconic franchise with an iconic look, his commitment didn't last very long. In 2006, he sold the team, and the new owners moved the Sonics to Oklahoma City. But Schultz's aesthetic vision
队服看起来像是对他们在 70 年代末开始穿着的款式的一种更新。但是，如果说霍华德·舒尔茨致力于将超音速队打造成一个拥有标志性外观的标志性球队，那么他的这种执着并没有持续多久。2006 年，他卖掉了球队，新老板将超音速队搬到了俄克拉荷马城。但舒尔茨的审美愿景
rippled throughout the league. Throughout the odds, one team after another slowly returned to the old color schemes and lost their big graphic jerseys. Even the Raptors look has completely changed. This year the two main jerseys were red and white and they just say Raptors on the front in a simple font. No crazy claw marks, no dinosaurs. And it's like I've seen better inner-me-year old jerseys at college. Here is Tom O'Grady again. They're just, there's nothing to them. There's zero, they're lifeless.
却在整个联盟中产生了涟漪。整个 2000 年代，各支球队一队接一队地慢慢回归到旧的配色方案，并抛弃了他们的大图形球衣。甚至猛龙队的外观也发生了彻底的改变。今年的两款主配色球衣是红白相间的，正面用简单的字体写着“Raptors”（猛龙）。没有疯狂的爪痕，没有恐龙。这就好像我在大学里见过设计更好的队内赛球衣。这里再次请出汤姆·奥格雷迪。它们简直……毫无特色。简直是零，毫无生气。
And I don't get it. Say what you will about Tom O'Grady's jerseys, but they were not lifeless. His designs are mostly gone from the NBA now, but they live on in blog posts and listicles of people's favorite jerseys from NBA history, or their least favorite. In their 2015 list of the ugliest basketball jerseys of all time, sports illustrated wrote, quote, the Toronto Raptors cartoon dinosaur logo is one of the worst in all of sports. Thankfully, it will soon be extinct.
而且我无法理解。对汤姆·奥格雷迪的球衣随你怎么说，但它们绝对不是毫无生气的。他的设计现在大部分已经从 NBA 中消失了，但它们依然活在博客文章和人们评选 NBA 历史最爱（或最不爱）球衣的盘点列表里。在体育画报（Sports Illustrated）2015 年评选的有史以来最丑篮球球衣榜单中，他们写道：“引述：多伦多猛龙队的卡通恐龙标志是整个体育界最糟糕的标志之一。谢天谢地，它很快就会灭绝。”
But Tom doesn't mind when people call his designs GARISH or even ugly. He's proud of our actors, Jersey. It was meant to be provocative, it was meant to be kind of eye-catching. We could have taken and started out with, you know, a 72-point helvetica that says Toronto in a big number on the back and call it a day, but I think that would not have been a memorable identity or nor a great way to introduce a new team into a new market. And if people are still talking about it, then he did his job, right? I'm fine with the criticism about people thinking it's the worst thing ever because it certainly
但当人们称他的设计为艳俗甚至丑陋时，汤姆并不介意。他为猛龙队的球衣感到骄傲。它本意就是具有挑衅性的，本意就是引人注目的。我们本可以采用并从一个 72 号黑体字开始，上面写着“多伦多”，背面印着一个大数字，然后就大功告成了，但我认为那不会是一个令人难忘的身份标识，也不是将新球队引入新市场的绝佳方式。如果人们至今仍在谈论它，那么他就完成工作了，对吧？我不在乎别人批评它是有史以来最糟糕的东西，因为这当然
says that, you know, we noticed it, we have an opinion about it, we have a strong opinion about it, but we remember it and I think that's great. And the Raptor's original plan to hook kids with the happy meal of NBA jerseys. Love it or hate it. You could argue that it worked. Today, Toronto has a loyal fan base. And over the past five years, they've had some of the highest attendance numbers in the league. And as for those bold 90s jerseys, they haven't actually gone extinct. There are now entire companies that produce retro jerseys and many of the designs Tom O'Grady
说明，你知道的，我们注意到了它，我们对它有看法，我们有强烈的看法，但我们记住了它，我认为这很棒。至于猛龙队用快乐儿童餐式的 NBA 球衣吸引孩子们的最初计划。爱它或恨它。你可以说它成功了。今天，多伦多拥有了一批忠实的球迷基础。在过去五年里，他们的上座率一直在联盟中名列前茅。至于那些 90 年代的醒目球衣，它们其实并没有灭绝。现在有整家整家的公司在生产复古球衣，汤姆·奥格雷迪
and his team came up with are really popular. And one of the top sellers is a bright purple jersey with a jagged clawcut pinstripes and a red dinosaur, real blame, a basketball. The Toronto Raptors have won their way into the NBA finals and that Barney jersey is more desirable than ever. We'll have a report from the 99PI editor and Canadian Chris Baroubae after this. So I'm in the studio with Chris Baroubae. He's our resident Canadian special projects editor and a long suffering Raptors fan who is very excited that the Raptors are in the finals.
和他的团队想出的许多设计都非常受欢迎。其中最畅销的产品之一就是一件亮紫色的球衣，上面有锯齿状的爪痕细条纹和一个红色的恐龙，它真的一边运着球。多伦多猛龙队已经一路杀入 NBA 总决赛，那件巴尼球衣比以往任何时候都更受欢迎。接下来我们将听到 99PI 编辑兼加拿大人克里斯·巴鲁比的报道。我现在和克里斯·巴鲁比在录音室里。他是我们的常驻加拿大人、特别项目编辑，也是一个饱受折磨、对猛龙队打入总决赛感到无比兴奋的猛龙球迷。
I genuinely can't believe this is happening Roman. I have been a Raptors fan since I was eight years old and I am in my early 30s. So it has been a great deal of sports related suffering in my life. So I want to count for all that suffering. I mean, why has it been so hard to be a fan of the Raptors? In the early days, it was really tricky because the team came to Toronto. Nobody in Toronto cared about basketball over hockey. In the really early days, they actually played in a baseball stadium because the basketball
罗曼，我真心不敢相信这一切正在发生。我从八岁起就是猛龙球迷，而我现在三十出头。所以我的生命中经历了很多与体育相关的折磨。所以我得细数一下所有的这些折磨。我的意思是，为什么当猛龙队的球迷这么难？在早期，这真的很棘手，因为球队来到了多伦多。多伦多没有人关心篮球胜过冰球。在非常早期的日子里，他们实际上是在一个棒球场里打比赛，因为篮球
stadium wasn't ready yet. So they set them up in this baseball stadium. And if you had like 15,000 fans, like that's a good number of basketball fans, but a baseball stadium seats like 45,000 people. So they just had these rows of empty seats with tarps over them. When you'd go to the game, it was really disperiding.
馆还没准备好。所以他们把球馆设在这个棒球场里。如果你有大约 15,000 名球迷，这对于篮球迷来说是个不错的数字，但棒球场能容纳大约 45,000 人。所以他们只能搞出这些盖着防水布的空座位排。当你去现场看球时，这真的很令人沮丧。
And players just really didn't want to play in Canada partly because of stereotypes about it's too cold, and the taxes are high. I mean, the taxes are also high in places like California comparatively, but people didn't want to move up here. But very famously, one player just refused to come. Alonso Morning was like traded to the Raptors and he said, yeah, I'm just not going to do that.
而且球员们真的不想在加拿大打球，部分原因是出于“天气太冷、税收很高”的刻板印象。我的意思是，相比之下，像加州这样的地方税收也很高，但人们就是不想搬到这里来。最著名的是，曾有一名球员直接拒绝前来。阿朗佐·莫宁（Alonzo Mourning）被交易到猛龙队时，他说：“是的，我才不干呢。”
And they had to like, create them somewhere else. And players kept having these like weird excuses for not being here. Like, there was this guy, Antonio Davis, who played for the team, who said he was actually like worried about his kids learning the metric system. Like, that was an anxiety for him. So there was this like fatalism to Raptor's fandom mirror. It's like nobody wants to play here. It's a place that, you know, a player,
他们不得不把他交易到别的地方去。而且球员们总是有各种奇怪的借口不来这里。比如，有个叫安东尼奥·戴维斯（Antonio Davis）的球员，曾在该队效力，他说他其实有点担心自己的孩子学习公制单位。对来说，这甚至成了一种焦虑。所以猛龙队的球迷文化中有一种宿命论。感觉就像没人愿意在这里打球。这是一个，你知道的，球员们
it's not seen as like a desirable location for players to end up. And then, you know, we had to wear this uniform in the really early days with the Raptor on it and the bright purple. And lots of players didn't like that. Like lots of players were saying, like, yeah, this is the only profession where like you hit the very top of your field and then you have to wear a purple dinosaur uniform. Unless your field is being Bernie the dinosaur, that's the only other one.
不会认为这是一个最终想去的理想目的地的城市。然后，你知道的，在早期我们必须穿着这件印有猛龙图案、亮紫色的队服。很多球员其实并不喜欢这样。很多球员都在说：“是的，这是唯一一个你达到了你所在领域的巅峰，却不得不穿上一身紫色恐龙制服的职业。”除非你的职业是扮演恐龙巴尼，那是唯一的例外。
But it sounds like people kind of like that Jersey now, right? It's true. I think people have really come around on it, especially with the playoffs happening now. So, I've had all these friends who have been going up to buy Raptors gear and there've been lined up south the door and all the dinosaur stuff for the most part is just completely sold out.
但听起来人们现在挺喜欢那件球衣的，对吧？确实如此。我觉得人们真的开始接受它了，特别是随着季后赛的进行。所以，我所有的朋友最近都在抢购猛龙队的周边，店门外排起了长队，所有恐龙主题的东西基本上都彻底卖光了。
And I went to this vintage store actually, fairly close to where I am called Inventage We Trust. It's run by this guy named Josh Brooder. And he's been selling Raptors merchandise forever and he is Toronto born and raised. Me and Sean taller, Toronto Nians. We would say Toronto Nians, but you would say Toronto Nians, yeah.
我其实还去了一家离我挺近的复古服装店，叫做“We Trust 收藏”（In Vintage We Trust）。这家店由一个叫乔什·布鲁德（Josh Brooder）的人经营。他一直在卖猛龙队的周边商品，而且他是多伦多土生土长的本地人。我和肖恩·托勒，多伦多本地人。我们会说“Toronto Nians”（多伦多本地人），但你会说“Toronto Nians”，对吧。
And my missing something, what is the difference between those two things you just said? Yeah, well, Toronto Nians, if you hit that last T, that shows that you're not from here. It's people who are from here say Toronto. Oh, I see. You can drop the last T. I see. So it's the Toronto Raptors, not the Toronto Raptors.
我是不是漏掉了什么，你刚才说的这两者有什么区别？对啊，如果是“Toronto Nians”，如果你发了最后一个 T 的音，那就说明你不是这里的人。本地人说的时候会说“Toron-to”。哦，我明白了。你可以不发最后一个 T 的音。我明白了。所以是“多伦多猛龙队”（Toronto Raptors），而不是“多伦多猛龙队”（Toronto-Raptors）。
Yeah. If you want to sound credible in the next few days, you say the Toronto Raptors. So Josh and his partner, Shantel, they run this vintage store and he says the last few weeks, he's been getting requests like every half hour for some version of the purple dinosaur uniform from the early days. And Josh, he's like everybody, he knows the dinosaur is a pretty ridiculous look. It almost makes no sense. Like the actual logo is a dinosaur, But the actual logo is a dinosaur, whole dribbling abasque of all one way. He's turning around the other way, and his toes are coming out of a pair of sneakers.
对。如果你想在接下来的几天里听起来像个地道的多伦多本地人，你就要说“Toronto Raptors”。所以乔什和他的合伙人尚泰尔经营着这家复古服装店，他说在过去的几周里，他每隔半小时就会收到顾客的要求，想要寻找早期紫色恐龙队服的某个版本。而乔什，他就像所有人一样，知道这只恐龙看起来相当荒谬。这几乎毫无道理。比如实际上的标志是一只恐龙，但真正的标志是一只恐龙，一边运着篮球往一个方向走。他却转过身向另一个方向，脚趾还露在一双运动鞋外面。
It's completely absurd and ridiculous, and not only is it like a logo on a hat as a fan, the players are literally wearing this logo on their jerseys. It's insane. So everyone wants the Barney jersey, but also everyone kind of acknowledges that it's a little bit silly. So why do people like it now? Talking to Josh, I came away with two things.
这完全是荒谬绝伦的，不仅作为球迷把它当成帽子上的标志，球员们居然真的在球衣上穿着这个标志。这太疯狂了。所以每个人都想要巴尼球衣，但同时每个人又都承认它确实有点傻。那为什么现在的人们还喜欢它呢？在与乔什交谈后，我总结出两点原因。
So the first is that the team is winning and nobody wants to look like a bandwagon fan. So nobody wants to look like they've heard about the rules of basketball in the last two weeks. They just realized this is something they're obsessed with. So everybody wants to make it seem like they've been there since the beginning. So if you wear the purple dyno jersey, you look credible. So especially if it's a really obscure player, like Josh told me he's been getting requests for people like Oliver Miller, who I had to look up.
首先是球队赢球了，没有人想看起来像个跟风球迷。所以没人想让人觉得他们在过去两周才刚刚听说篮球规则。他们只是意识到这是他们狂热痴迷的东西。所以每个人都想表现得好像他们从一开始就在这里支持球队一样。所以如果你穿上那件紫色恐龙球衣，你看起来就很地道。特别是如果这是一位非常冷门的球员，比如乔什告诉我，有人向他求购奥利弗·米勒（Oliver Miller）的球衣，我都不得不去查一下这个人是谁。
I had no idea who that was and I cared about the team forever. So people are spending like all this money to get these jerseys of players nobody's ever heard of. The other thing is nostalgia, right? Nostalgia does not have to make sense. It doesn't have to be something that is pretty or nice. And this is what Josh says vintage is all about. It's about what the logo evokes for people. It's what time it sends you back to. And when you look at that
我根本不知道他是谁，尽管我一直都非常关注这支球队。所以人们花了大把的钱去买那些根本没人听过的球员的球衣。另一个原因就是情怀，对吧？情怀不需要讲道理。它不需要是那种漂亮或精致的东西。这就是乔什所说的复古的全部意义所在。它关乎这个标志能为人们唤起怎样的记忆。它把你带回了哪一段时光。当你看到那个
Raptors uniform, when you look at that purple on the Jersey, that is the 90s. They reminds me of like Space Jam of like this era when there was so much silly basketball stuff happening. And it really just sends you back to that time. The logo is cartoonish and it's very reminiscent of a specific era. And people love reliving parts of their lives through tangible items, things that they can touch and feel. That's why people are paying out to own an original piece because they're investing in their past. So obviously the Raptors are not wearing the purple uniform from the 90s in the finals right now. They're wearing their current uniform, which is pretty simple. It's pretty clean.
猛龙队的队服，当你看着球衣上的那一抹紫色，那就是 90 年代。它让我想起《空中大灌篮》（Space Jam），想起那个充斥着各种滑稽篮球玩意的时代。它真的把你瞬间带回了那个年代。这个标志充满了卡通感，非常让人联想起那个特定的时代。人们喜欢通过有形的事物——那些他们可以触摸和感受的东西——来重温他们生活中的片段。这就是为什么人们花大价钱去拥有一件原版藏品，因为他们在投资自己的过去。所以很显然，猛龙队现在在总决赛中并没有穿着 90 年代的紫色队服。他们穿着现在的队服，设计相当简洁。相当干净。
It's like a white uniform with the black Sans The White San Serif fonts, the word Raptors across the front. And then sometimes they wear a red uniform with the white Sanseriff raptors across the front. And then Roman, this is where it gets very exciting. They have a third uniform, which is black with a white Sanseriff raptors across the front. That's when it gets really exciting. I mean, you're mixing it up.
就像是一件白色的队服，上面印着黑色的无衬线字体，正面写着“Raptors”字样。有时候他们会穿红色的队服，正面写着白色的无衬线“Raptors”字样。然后，罗曼，最让人激动的部分来了。他们还有第三套队服，是黑色的，正面印着白色的无衬线“Raptors”字样。这才是真正让人激动的时候。我的意思是，你们真的是在花样翻新。
But I have seen this one that's like, it says North on it. What is, do you describe that one for us? Yeah, they call that the city Jersey. It's a red Jersey. It has like a white chevron. So it's like this white arrow pointing up. And it says North on it. I actually think that one's pretty stylish. Like I like that one the best of their current uniforms. But with all of them, it's like they're good design, they're very clean, they're very simple, and ultimately they're very safe.
但我见过一款上面写着“North”（北方）的球衣。那是哪一款？你能帮我们描述一下吗？对，他们称之为城市版球衣（City Jersey）。那是一件红色的球衣。上面有一个白色的雪佛龙图案。就像是一个指向上的白色箭头。上面写着“North”。我其实觉得那一款挺时尚的。在他们现有的队服里，我最喜欢那一件。但对于所有这些球衣来说，它们都是好设计，非常干净，非常简单，说到底也非常稳妥。
The current Raptors uniform, it doesn't have a lot of, umph. It's kind of weird for me to look at a Raptors jersey with no purple in it. I get it like you got to move away from the purple for a few years, but like, why isn't the Dino Jersey being worn as an alternate by the team at this point?
现如今的猛龙队队服，缺乏了一点……冲击力。对我而言，看着一件完全没有紫色的猛龙队球衣感觉有点怪。我理解，你可能必须在几年内避开紫色，但是，为什么球队现在不把恐龙球衣作为客场替补球衣穿呢？
Like, how crazy would a fan get for a quite Leonard Raptors Dino Jersey? Like, could you imagine? Ha ha ha. Give the people what they want. At the time we're recording this, Game 5 has just happened. The series is still alive. The Raptors have one or two chances to make this happen.
如果伦纳德（Kawaii Leonard）穿上一件猛龙队的恐龙球衣，粉丝们会有多疯狂？你能想象吗？哈哈。满足人民群众的要求吧。在我们录制这期节目的时候，第五场比赛刚刚结束。系列赛仍然悬念迭起。猛龙队还有一两次机会来锁定胜局。
So, Kauai Leonard, I know you are an avid listener of, of design podcasts. See if you can make this happen before the finals are over. Oh, it would be so great if this showed up on the court at Oracle. I mean, oh my god, I would love it. All right, thank you, Chris. Thank you, Roman. 99% of Asible was produced this week by Whitney Jones and Emmett Fitzgerald, with an assist from our new editor, Chris Barube.
所以，卡哇伊·伦纳德，我知道你是设计类播客的忠实听众。看看你能不能在总决赛结束前把这事儿办成。哦，如果这件球衣能出现在甲骨文球馆（Oracle）的赛场上，那该有多棒啊。我的天哪，我太想看到了。好的，谢谢你，克里斯。谢谢你，罗曼。本周的 99% Invisible 由惠特尼·琼斯和埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，我们的新编辑克里斯·巴鲁比提供了协助。
Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Rial. Kitty Mingle is the senior producer, Kurt Colstad, Chris Baroube. Mix and Tech Production by Sherefusif Music by Sean Rial. Kidding Mingle is the senior producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor, Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffman, Taren Mazza, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco, in produced, Unradio Row, In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California.
混音和技术制作由谢里·富塞夫（Sherry Wu）负责，音乐由肖恩·赖尔（Sean Rial）创作。基蒂·米勒（Kitty Mingle）是高级制作人，柯特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffman）、塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）、维维安·李（Vivian Lee）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg），以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 电台的项目，在美丽、阳光明媚的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街制作。
99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show in joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or a Quran Instagram Tumblr and Reddit too. But you can tell us all about your favorite
99% Invisible 是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚定的独立集体。您可以在 radiotopia.fm 上找到所有这些节目。您可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @我（Roman Mars）并在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上 @99PI。不过你可以在我们的网站 99PI.org 上告诉我们你最喜欢的
NBA Jersey on our website, it's 99PI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
NBA 球衣。来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。